[Applaus]
[Musik]
freitag 13 märz 2020 das spital lag der
etat in locarno macht sich bereit
schwerpunkt spital zu werden für corona
patienten im tessin die nicht kobelt
kommen hierhin noch wird ins wartezimmer
dort haben wir vier boxen aufgestellt im
wartezimmer gibt es vier betten vier
betten für kurven schwere notfälle die
nicht beatmet werden müssen
der rest ist intensivstation hier muss
es immer offen sein wenn es stark regnet
gibt es sonst einen sturzbach
[Musik]
von morgen an kommen die leute auf diese
station vor allem in die 42 wo die liebe
nie waren die ist jetzt ein zweier
zimmer bis zu 21 und 22 keinen kontakt
und schutz vor treppchen
im moment müssen die masken genügen die
überzüge kommen noch die idee ist das
eine ins zimmer geht und die andere
draußen bleibt
wir arbeiten paarweise wir haben
genügend material für inhalationen
sauerstoff von allem
wir sind bereit ist jetzt klar dass wir
die röntgenaufnahmen zu machen
sauerstoff flaschen für den transport
unseren wenn sich der zustand des
patienten verschlechtert entscheidet der
arzt ob er auf die intensivstation kommt
dafür haben wir einen notfallplan
es sind alles patienten isoliert werden
müssen
wir haben unterstützung bekommen hilfe
und wir werden schon schaffen uns zu
organisieren
jetzt eröffnen sie dann den vierten
stock weil es bei uns praktisch voll ist
schon von morgen ankommen 7 pflegende am
morgen sieben am nachmittag und vier in
der nacht ab heute ist es die hauptsache
dass wir wissen wo jeder ist damit wir
ihn finden wenn man ihn braucht
nach sieben patienten in der chirurgie c
dort hat es 58 plätze und wenn noch
sieben kommen ist es voll
dann beginnen wir auch den vierten stock
zu füllen die chirurgie und gynäkologie
stationen werden umgerüstet für
patienten mit kubik 19
die aus dem kokon spital lugano ist vor
45 minuten abgefahren und die aus der
privaten praxis kommt in den notfall
[Musik]
die patientinnen und patienten kommen
aus dem ganzen kanton
sie werden nach genauen anleitungen
begleitet je nach schweregrad kommen die
patienten auf unterschiedliche stationen
[Musik]
diese frau kommt direkt ins 207 dorthin
der blauen linie entlang und dann nach
rechts dort sind die lifte
ich will nicht da bleiben wo die
schwerkranken sind ich hatte eine
transplantation um ein immunsystem ist
kaputt also wenn ich nicht hier bleiben
zuerst haben sie gesagt es sei
gefährlich für mich und ich soll ihn
nicht hier bleiben und jetzt bin ich
schon fünf stunden hier
ich will doch nicht krank werden gehen
sie nach dort hinten
ich wähle hinaus an die luft dort hin
dort ist der abstand genug russ der
stress in anführungszeichen liegt
manchmal eher in der kommunikation
aber wir schaffen es wir sind das
gewohnt
klar ist dass jetzt eine andere
situation aber schwierige unterhaltungen
wie diese hat mir auch schon
wir lernen damit umzugehen hier in der
notfallstation sind wir daran den
patienten fluss zu organisieren damit
wir die patienten mit atemproblemen und
oder dem verdacht oder schon einer
diagnose auf corona absondern können
hier müssen wir voraus denken und alles
für den schlimmsten fall bereit machen
und warten bis es losgeht
schon in den vergangenen 48 stunden ist
der rhythmus schneller geworden
aber im moment ist alles in
anführungszeichen unter kontrolle
wir sind ja auch sonst auf dem spiel
das ist nicht außergewöhnlich oder
selten in unserer arbeit
[Musik]
fieber und husten seit samstag ich weiß
nicht wo ich es auf gelesen habe weil
ich nicht viel unterwegs bin ich bin
immer zu hause gut sehr wahrscheinlich
werden wir alle oder ein teil von uns
daran erkannten
wichtig ist dass dies abwechselnd
geschieht damit einer der krank wird
gesund werden und wieder an die arbeit
zurückkehren kann
damit dann jemand anders krank werden
kann leben sie allein zu hause nein das
heißt ich habe zwei schwestern eine
neben und eine über mir und wie geht es
denen die haben im moment nichts und
haben sie sie in letzter zeit getroffen
sie ist positiv aber es ist auch wichtig
zu wissen ob sie eine grippe hat oder
nicht
dann kommt sie auf eine andere abteilung
jemand mit grippe kommt nicht an den
gleichen ort wie jemand der kogit 19
positiv ist sonst stecken sie sich auch
noch mit grippe an
aber zwei die note haben können auch im
gleichen zimmer liegen
ok 30 minuten
[Musik]
ja
ein teil des personals ist von auswärts
zurückgeholt worden
aus anderen funktionen ich zum beispiel
bin als ausbildnerin tätig andere
kolleginnen kommen aus der ambulanten
betreuung
wir sind alle spezialisiert wir haben
mit der zeit unserem weg gemacht und
jetzt haben sie uns gefragt ob er
wiederkommen könnten
so sind wir zurückgekommen innerhalb von
vier tagen haben sie zwei neue stationen
eröffnet das sagt doch alles
innerhalb weniger tage wurden 45 pflegen
der und 16 ärztinnen und ärzte aus
anderen akutspitälern in die
intensivstation von locarno versetzt
unsere schichten dauern zwölf stunden
und 45 minuten also fast 13
weil es zwölf stunden sind plus drei
viertelstunden für die übergabe im
normalfall machen wir das nicht länger
als drei oder vier tage aber jetzt
stehen wir voll zur verfügung und sind
praktisch immer hier wenn es nötig ist
geht man hört wer aus dem ausland kommt
wie ich bleibt hier und steht zur
verfügung solange es nötig ist
[Musik]
das sage ich immer verschieden wir die
spitze so ist dass die neuen fälle
nehmen schon jetzt tag für tag zu und
nach zwölf tagen sind es schon mehr als
vorausgesagt
also die neuen fälle nehmen jeden tag zu
und schon jetzt sind es mehr als nach
dem schlechtesten szenario
ich glaube zwei sind auf der station
gestorben und einem patienten auf der
intensivstation geht es sehr schlecht
alles was man vorausgesagt hat tritt
jetzt ein
nach einer woche wissen wir ob es ihnen
besser geht oder schlechter moment wie
schon gestern gesagt haben müssen wir
warten und beobachten was in den
nächsten 24 stunden passiert wir geben
antibiotika und anti virus medikamente
und beatmen
der zustand ist stabil ihnen geht es gut
im rahmen des möglichen klar dass glaube
es tut mir wirklich leid senior aber
jetzt gerade auf wiederhören
[Musik]
ich komme während ihr ihn vorbereitet
mache ich bei ihr fertig also leute auf
drei geht's los
wenn wir die patienten auf den bauch
legen geht der sauerstoff viel besser
ins blut sie bleiben viele stunden lang
so liegen dann drehen wir sie beim sonst
druckstellen geben könnte und wir sehen
auch wie sie darauf reagiert haben und
dann drehen wir sie wieder so machen wir
es mindestens sieben oder zehn tage lang
[Musik]
die pfleger und ärzte und auch alle
anderen hier wir sehen keine gesichter
mehr
die leute haben also keine namen und
vornamen sind einfach menschen für die
wir uns einsetzen um sie zu retten
und das verbindet uns alle hier
[Musik]
hier war bis vor sechs jahren die alte
im prinzip station dann diente sie als
tagesklinik und jetzt haben wir sie in
24 stunden wieder in eine
intensivstation umgewandelt
[Musik]
wir pflegen sind auf solche sachen
vorbereitet weil wir seit langem mit dem
tod zu tun haben
ich bin eine alte kämpferin und habe
schon viel gesehen aber das jetzt ist
etwas völlig anderes es ist wirklich
schwierig die verwandten könne nicht
kennen
diese patienten sind allein stellen sie
sich vor wie ihre verwandten zu hause
angst haben und ihre liebsten nicht
besuchen können
wir versuchen ihnen so nah wie möglich
zu sein als ob sie unsere verwandten
wären aber es ist schon schwierig eine
ganz andere situation
ich wohne im italienischen kann ob meine
beiden kinder habe ich bei meinen eltern
untergebracht und ich bleibe hier bis
diese schlimme zeit vorbei ist und man
nicht hier nicht mehr braucht
[Musik]
theoretisch müssten wir eine halbe
stunde außerhalb der station pause
machen aber das schaffen wir gar nicht
so bleiben wir hier und essen was sie
uns aus der kantine gebracht haben jetzt
kommt so viel arbeit aufs mal
die calle änderungen vor allem das ganze
spital ist auf den kopf gestellt all die
weisungen die jeden tag in jeden tag
dietz etwas neues jeden tag kommt neues
personal
man muss sich daran gewöhnen und einfach
wissen mit wem man gerade arbeitet
wir würden gerne mehr tun aber wir haben
keine zeit
diese patienten sind alle wirklich
allein und ob es ihnen gut oder schlecht
geht
sie haben nur uns war jemand anders sein
kann
[Musik]
bei mir hat es für eine woche mit hohem
fieber bekommen
ich bin dann sofort zum arzt gegangen
dort war alles bereit
das rennteam ging gut aber ich hatte
erhöhte blutwerte und dann hat man
weitere untersuchungen gemacht weil mein
immunsystem unterdrückt ist
sie haben dann einen virus abstrich
gemacht einen normalen und einen auf
corona wenn man dann hört dass der
normale virus abstriche in ordnung ist
und sie auf die resultate des gruner
abstrichs warten
hört man auf zu leben am montag bekam
ich dann die bestätigung
dann geht einem so viel durch den kopf
vor allem wenn man gesundheitsprobleme
nach zwei tagen ist es schlimmer
geworden
ich konnte dann nicht mehr gut atmen und
rief die ambulanz mitten in der nacht
haben sie mich hierher nach lokaler
gebracht
nicht auf der intensivstation und
erhalte sauerstoff lässt dann haben sie
ja nur eine neue behandlung getestet die
in den nächsten 24 bis 48 stunden würden
und diese lungenentzündung etwas stoppen
sollte ich hoffe dass sie es schaffen
weil es eine furchtbare zeit
die es schaffen haben glück oder die die
nur wenige symptome haben aber wir sind
nicht alle gleich
[Musik]
wir haben keine gegensprechanlage wir
können nicht anders kommunizieren
[Musik]
seit ein paar tagen geht es mir besser
das fieber ist gesunken und seit heute
morgen habe ich wieder appetit
zehn tage lang habe ich nichts gegessen
jetzt bin ich wieder zuversichtlich weil
ich sehe dass es besser geht als sie das
virus entdeckt haben
eines morgens bin ich aufgewacht
schon am abend hatte ich etwas fieber
und am morgen waren es dann 38 5 grad
da ich eine transplantation hatte rief
ich im spital und coco meiner ärztin an
sagte ich solle schnell her kommen für
einen abstrich sind wir sofort ruhe
hätten und bin nicht mehr nach hause
zurückgekehrt
ich bin zum notfall gegangen weil ich
nicht wusste was los war
ich war ohnmächtig geworden
dann haben sie mich zur sicherheit
gründlich untersucht ich war ohnmächtig
und hatte wahrscheinlich einen blutdruck
abfallen sie haben also alles
kontrolliert und auch einen test auf
corona virus und krippe gemacht der
krippe test war negativ aber die auf das
corona beer russland positiv da ich zu
einer risikogruppe gehöre weil ich
asthma habe haben die ärzte mich zur
sicherheit wie ein paar tage hier
behalten um zu sehen wie die krankheit
sich entwickelt die ersten tage sind
sehr wichtig wenn sich die situation in
den ersten tagen nicht verschlechtert
kann man wieder gesund werden
[Musik]
damit der betrieb nicht zusammenbricht
muss andauernd neu geplant werden tag
für tag kommen neue fälle dazu
mehr als erwartet das spital hat 210
betten bereitgestellt
180 normale und 30 in der intensivpflege
aber das sind bereits zu wenig wir
stellen hier vier provisorische boxen
auch für schwer kranke patienten die in
den notfall kommen zu wollen wir so gut
wie möglich die anderen entlasten damit
mehr platz bleibt für die
intensivtherapie sie haben eine infusion
gelegt und machen jetzt die abstriche
dann mache ich eine blut gas messung
links
heute lehren wir praktisch den ganzen
dritten stock da bleiben bis mittwoch
höchstens sechs patienten am donnerstag
klären wir die geriatrie
die haben wir noch ausgelassen jetzt
werden dort nochmals 14 betten fragen
jetzt die physiotherapeuten andere
spitäler gekommen um uns zu helfen
[Musik]
weißt du wie viele geräte die haben wir
möchten wissen wie viele für die
patienten verfügbar sind
[Musik]
wenn man diese dinge aus china hört
denkt man immer man sei besser als die
anderen und bei uns stören sie nicht
aber jetzt müssen wir uns eingestehen
dass die chinesen nicht schlechter sind
als wir
sie sind genau so kommt wie wir und wir
sind genauso machtlos wie sie jetzt
sterben die leute auch hier
wenn es so weitergeht wird mit unseren
14 betten plätzen in der lungen station
die ganze kapazität den drei tagen
ausgeschöpft sein
weil jetzt kommen noch zwölf patienten
von außerhalb wissen wir wie viele aus
dem motto chenery sind weil ab mittag
müssen sie ins spital nach lugano biel
ab heute mittag an coco die korona
patienten aufnehmen
alle patienten aus dem motto chenery
müssen ins moko verlegt werden auch die
intensiv fälle wir alle das verlangsamt
die eintritte und verschafft uns mehr
platz
[Musik]
das einzige gefühl das ich habe ist dass
wir zu langsam waren zu wenig tüchtig
und zu wenig fähig das ist das einzige
aber sie tun ihr möglichstes
das sehen wir dann im juni
im juni ziehen wir bilanz dann sehen wir
ob wir fähig waren oder nicht
[Musik]